hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hush into the darkness
now there's an indie game that was
released just a little bit ago where you
play as a child wandering into the
darkness and I don't know much more than
that but it was enough to interest me
into playing and I might actually play a
few times in case it turns out to be
amazing oh cool
hello
reminds me of Foster's Home for
Imaginary Friends seems like it oh yeah
oh yeah it definitely looks good
probably not haunted in any way oh I'm
playing it's so dark are there any lamps
around I have no idea how am i playing
with a gamepad oh okay that probably a
little bit better okay hello who are you
I'm Jevon they don't let us go upstairs
sorry the others are in the common room
to your right
what are you the bouncer alright okay
I'm Devin all right thanks oh I can't
skip the dialogue okay I just got to
read very slowly maybe no yes oh okay I
can't skip the dialogue never mind I'm
just a dumb dumb hey there i'm ashlyn
this is gogo what are your names
well okay then
good goodbye can I do anything no not
yet hello i'm ashlyn me and gogo are
gonna have a great time
reminds me of jojo poor Jojo hello hello
okay they don't want it hey you stop
running for a little bit doctor okay
you're a ghost never mind okay ah lo
this place is really creepy I mean not
that I expected any music to actually be
playing here but still still really
creepy oh that's really cool though I
liked it whoa nice butt crack
hi oh okay
am i running now why on I go to there
what's the one in the hell's this
happened and why whoa
okay this took a turn for the worst very
quickly
Oh grab he's gonna get me no you don't
know you don't know you know I'm gonna
cut the corner I'm gonna drift I learned
a lot about drifting now well not much
but I mean I learned something that's
gonna get me oh he's gonna get me no no
no no no no I'm a super jugger I'm a
super dear okay all right okay enough
panicking
what am i a big baby I'm seven go go
help me help me go you goddamn it
getting guess is that that exactly
ouch ouch
yep well that didn't stop him at all
that just slowed me down Oh
oh crap oh crap oh crap oh crap oh this
is the wrong way okay but now would be a
good time to put on the turbo boosters
kid and please ways good please somehow
go faster okay so anyway this is an
interesting start to the game I mean
it's really cool that they had the
animated sequences and everything but it
seems like sudden jump into being chased
by a big behemoth child yes run quickly
please oh man
this kids not nice Oh Kate I don't want
to venture out on a limb but maybe they
should hire that nanny that beats
children into submission with her pillow
seems like just might have been the
situation where maybe this song same
universe oh okay
ow probably okay get up get up Ashlyn we
must leave now or stay here forever
I guess why am I here in the first place
okay what the hell happened it's so
bizarre I mean it was bizarre that I was
going into Foster's home for the
imaginary kids and then everything else
that happened this is go go companion
favorite toy overall swell guy swing go
go around knock down the fools who stand
in your bath oh the fools now are they I
think I might have been a fool for
walking into this house it obstacles to
get rid of them
Go Go forgives you for lose using it
like that okay all right cool hey yeah
Wow Gogu is very much like a sward also
seems to be shooting some energy beams
so dark why are there no lamps around
trapped in the basement so I go I go
slower in the darkness because of oh who
the hell is that
hello hey there what are you drawing oh
this door seems to be missing some
drawings so I thought I'd make new ones
but mine just don't seem to fit you
don't seem to be doing anything actually
seriously why aren't there more lights
in this place good question also demons
why the demons demons are weird huh not
sure a seven-year-old apparently good
okay BAM wow this is so much different
than I was expecting it to be dodging
may also be helpful so keep that in mind
cool what button do i press to do that
oh that button okay alrighty then weird
huh barrel goddamn barrel huh okay this
so bizarre I never expected it to be
like this it's so cool
hey get out of here I'm not doing
anything to this guy oh there we go I
wasn't quite hitting I need to get up a
little closer okay there we go the
combat mechanic is a little bit floaty
I'd call it not doesn't seem like I'm
making solid connections to everything
that I'm trying to hit but whoa hey oh
oh no no no no whoa no no no no no yeah
why didn't that work next yeah it just
it just does not often seem like I'm
connecting to everything wow what she
just looked he totally just changed
direction that was not fair huh I only
have one heart left I am NOT playing
this to the best of my ability but then
again I just got to introduce to
everything so it's kind of a strange new
concept to me yeah maybe I could sneak
around it's dark Wireless ooh okay never
mind okay bad bad bad bad bad bad bad
bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad okay
maybe I'm not gonna go that way first
this seems to be bad for my health good
yeah I got a cool down on my roll I say
it seems weird that I have combat
training time to get back to the light
go go
yes indeed time to get back to the light
time to get to a place where things
aren't trying to murder me which seems
to be everywhere
I wish there were more lights I just
can't find any
well I died
really I just straight up rolled over
and died
okay so stay out of the darkness okay
that's a that's a that's a new thing
that I just learned I'm building a lot
of skills here all right I don't have
anything not yet anyway all right go go
let's go go
it EDD okay going into the darkness
again but not staying in the darkness
for too long so I need to follow the
path of light but I need to get a little
better in combat before I'm able to
actually do what I need to do so let me
talk to this guy again hey what are you
drawing with so dark weren't there more
lamps I know I know I know okay so let's
try to beat these barrels down without
getting murdered too much cuz that's my
main problem
okay come at me bro I'm seven year old
girl with a stuffed toy what do you got
you got a whole lot of nothing okay so
that connected
okay yeah it seems really floaty there's
not a very clear distinction to what I'm
hitting and what I'm aiming at come on
who else is out okay you guys
god damn it come on come on come on OOP
okay boom so what how'd that hit me okay
there's one down whoa okay here we go
damn it how did that hit me it shouldn't
have hit me the animation cycle is also
a little off there we go okay got it got
it got it but man I lost two hearts
already how is this happening
how am I supposed to be able to beat
this hey listen this is this is tough
this throws you into the fray real quick
and doesn't give a good understanding is
like the combat mechanics ass you he did
a jump attack okay there we go okay so
that's something I still don't know how
to recover health though doesn't mean it
seems like I'm just kind of how did he
go through that what a little douche
nozzle want you okay whoa no no okay
okay there we go got him got him I got
hurt again huh oh man come on huh I'm
trying my best here I really am
not the guy over here woo woo ah dammit
god oh no oh no no no no no no no no no
what I'm stuck in it what what happened
what happened what happened oh man I
really want to like this game I'm just
gonna try to run away and not fight cuz
maybe not fighting is what I'm supposed
to do at this time
and then hopefully hopefully I'll be
able to eat okay never mind I that's a
trap okay wow wow wow wow okay wow wow
wow get out get out of get out of the
way yeah okay what is that was that a
book moth was that a book buff oh no oh
no oh no oh
dodge dodge dodge roll tuck and roll
nope nope nope stuck dime suck oh okay
and we're dead okay all right there
might be something I'm doing wrong here
there might definitely be but it seems a
little tedious to have to fight through
every single enemy in the manner that it
is set up because you guys are watching
it but you guys aren't I mean you guys
are watching you can see that it's very
hard to determine what connects very
hard to determine what the enemies like
actually doing to me how the enemy is
doing it and how what I'm doing is
impacting like my damage and how I can
avoid there it's not very clear on
exactly what I'm gonna do so I'm gonna
give it one more try and I'm gonna
really take my time I'm gonna take my
time going through everything try to
take my time to avoid as much damage as
possible I'm gonna go very very very
carefully on beating these guys so give
me a second I will try my very best
there we go one down no damage one down
no damage okay okay so the trick is to
take more time when going back for the
attack because I can't go in earlier
else I'll just be hit when I think the
animation cycle is over but there
actually is quite a bit of a delay
before that happens it's also a little
weird that all the enemies take exactly
five hits to deal with and I don't know
if I have time to make a combo in there
but because the attack cycle is very
linear and changes and there is like
combos to be made but I don't understand
like how they are made just yet still
working on that whoa damn it ah damn it
oh god why is he running attack okay
plus two hearts on one barrel Wow come
on there we go okay dad dad still don't
know how to recover health like that's
another it's another thing that's that's
a very questionable because just getting
getting this many hearts and then not
being able to do anything afterwards wow
that guy came out of the woodwork come
on come on come on let's go let's go
fight in here fight in here
what's doing yeah I mean it is really
interesting there's a lot of redeeming
qualities that drew me to the game
because the art style is very
interesting the dungeon crawler aspect
of it is very unique especially
considering that I'm playing as a child
but also it seems very punishing very
punishing for game mechanics that I
still haven't fully grasped yet oh come
on
right before I finished him off I got
greedy but trying to get one okay I'm
gonna try to go back and possibly see if
the kid might be able to fit tell me how
I heal something like that I'm not
entirely sure check okay check ah do you
see any exits what was that noise what
Oh am i dying was I was I in the
darkness right there dang it
okay whoops okay then
damnit I lost half a heart so weird
come on ok so next one we got a moth but
I only got one hit before I die oh crap
Oh Oh what I didn't even get a chance to
do anything and couldn't run away wow
wow wow ok alright so I guess I'm done
for now I really want to like this game
I wanted to like it because it seemed
charming it seemed unique and you know I
have a penchant for horror games
involved from the perspective of a child
which what I thought it was but this
isn't entirely a horror game
it started off interesting and the
animations were of real good quality I
liked them as a cutscene and the premise
was really interesting because it was a
mystery of why I was in an orphanage
anyway but that could be self explained
because obviously I'm an orphan of
course I would be an orphanage but and
then the weird kid that caused all the
other kids to glow I was into it I was
totally into it but the initial chase
sequence seemed kind of hokey and then
going into here the combat seems floaty
and I'm having trouble
I'm really trying I'm really trying not
to get hurt but I have no idea like is
there like a menu no there's not there's
no inventory there's no other buttons
that I could press there's just
directions attack and whatnot so there's
a lot that doesn't seem to be going on
that's fully implemented in this game
and I don't remember if this was an
early access game or if this was a fully
fledged game also I just noticed the
framerate is running really low here but
either way it is what it is so let me
know what you think of this in the
comments down below hopefully you
enjoyed this video anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the other indie games that I played in
the cut and loop description down below
all the annotations over there thanks
again everybody and as always I will see
you in the next video